good morning John in yo ass video you
were talking about how sometimes huge
shifts and global power structures
result in short-term catastrophe and
that made me think about how deeply
wonderful it is that we have gotten
through the last 73 years as a nuclear
species without completely destroying
ourselves there are a hundred and ninety
five ish countries only nine of them
have access to nuclear weapons North
Korea with a per capita GDP of thirteen
hundred dollars has proven that you
don't have to have a ton of money to
have a nuclear arsenal so why why why
don't more countries have nukes
this seems frankly like a tremendous
success one that should be celebrated
and studied and talked about and fretted
over maintaining so let's talk about why
more than seventy three years after the
development of the first nuclear weapons
so few countries have access to the
caveat I am NOT an expert in
international relations though I did
talk to some of those and I recorded one
of them as an interview that's on Hanks
channel right now but I will not be
going deep into any of this this is
something that lots of people study for
their whole lives the Wikipedia page on
a rams nuclear program by itself is more
than twenty thousand words you can I
think say a lot with some broad strokes
let's start with the list in order the
US tested its first nuclear bomb in 1945
the USSR followed in 1949 the UK and
1957 France in 1960 followed by China in
1964 that was a big spurt and it will
become important later Israel definitely
has secret nukes and may have had them
as early as the 1960s but they've never
tested one or admitted to having them
India developed nuclear weapons in the
70s South Africa built but probably
never tested fission bombs in the 1980s
before dismantling them in 1991 three
countries briefly had nuclear weapons
because when they started existing they
already had them Ukraine Belarus and
Kazakhstan all had nuclear weapons when
the USSR collapsed in 1994 they gave all
those weapons back to Russia in exchange
for assurances that Russia would never
challenge their borders which seems to
have turned out just fine
Pakistan surprised the world with a
nuclear test in 1998 and North Korea's
first test was 2006 if we look at it in
volume the US and Russia now Russia not
the USSR have the vast majority of new
weapons everyone else is pretty much
tied for last except for North Korea
which is extra last and this isn't to
say that other countries haven't tried
there have been nuclear programs in
Brazil Argentina Libya Iran Taiwan South
Korea there are more states that have
tried to get nuclear weapons then there
are states that have them the story of
why is complicated we're gonna start
with the 1960s when there was that big
spurt in new nuclear powers ending with
China that was seen rightfully as scary
possibly especially because it ended
with China a country that was Europeans
were like well that's not a European
country those people aren't white and
also Mao Zedong it's pretty scary dude
countries were exploring nuclear
programs just because their neighbors
were and if they didn't know their
neighbor wasn't they were gonna do it
and the international community was
realizing that this was gonna result in
a fully nuclear world but a lot of
people in the 60s didn't see this as
unusual or scary it was like okay well
there have been new weapons before
there's a new weapon again and the major
militaries are gonna have access to this
weapon an arms race was going on and
people were realizing that as
destructive as the bombs dropped in
Japan were they were only a fraction of
what could be done the Cold War started
raging people were building bomb
shelters students were having drills in
their schools and I think the world was
kind of realizing what it would be like
to have a world war with nuclear powers
on both sides so some countries got
together at the UN to create a treaty
that said hey look stop everyone sign
this piece of paper is saying that if
you don't already have nukes you will
not pursue nuclear weapons program and
over the years since every country has
been like actually yeah except for India
Pakistan and Israel who basically just
texted the UN one of those shrugging
emoticons all of those countries though
it took varying amounts of time
subsequently developed a nuclear weapon
the only country to have withdrawn from
that treaty North Korea so if you sign
that treaty it's literally against
international law to develop a nuclear
weapon but you don't have to sign the
treaty as South Sudan proved when it
became a country in 2011 and did not
sign the treaty at least yet so why do
countries sign it and why does so few
countries have nuclear weapons let's do
a list one it's freakin expensive too
pure
i uranium-235 though it is getting
cheaper too it is also expensive to have
the whole international community not
buy anything from your country and not
seventy thing to your country so that
raises the price of violating that tree
tree it's generally good to be like a
productive member of the international
community and to just agree with the
things that everyone agrees with for
international laws against selling
nuclear materials except in very
specific circumstances have actually
been really successful number five the
United States has it traditionally had a
lot of really good relationships with
its allies and has promised to protect
them with its giant arsenal of nuclear
warheads number six the seventy-three
years since World War two have been
remarkably prosperous and peaceful seven
we got very very lucky there is no
guarantee that if we somehow ran this
experiment again that we would end up
being in such a good situation and
finally number eight for those and also
many other reasons including
humanitarian ones most countries don't
want nuclear weapons they just don't
want them International Relations
experts talk about a norm against
nuclear weapons they're seen as taboo as
if developing a nuclear weapons program
is kind of seen as like wading into the
muck and if you look around at the
people who are creating these weapons
programs in recent years it is it's kind
of a mucky place I was surprised when I
started researching this video that
South Africa had a nuclear program why
did that happen because they were being
ostracized by the international
community for having an explicitly
racist government unfortunately the main
tool we have to discourage countries
from developing nuclear weapons can
sometimes force them even deeper into
that a country whether that's the leader
or its people or both are only gonna
want to develop nuclear weapons right
now if they are feeling threatened by
the international order and that happens
when the country is some combination of
unstable autocratic or has bad
relationships with its neighbors I'm not
saying that like we should do it a
different way I don't know what
sanctioning countries does hurt their
economies and further isolates them from
the benefits of being part of the
international community and of course
the people who are hurt most by
sanctions aren't the leaders and
government palaces unless there's some
kind of revolution it's the poor and the
more unstable and disconnected they are
the easier it is to tell a story about
how the whole world is out to get them
and
need to protect themselves and that is
how countries like North Korea and it's
feared maybe someday Iran slip through
these cracks so then we end up in a
world where all the new entrants to like
the nuclear club which is a weird one to
be in not that I'm not are the least
stable countries both because sanctions
somewhat maybe destabilize them but also
because stable countries who are
productive members of the international
community don't want nukes why would
they they're expensive they're illegal
they're hard to maintain and they don't
provide clear benefit and that one is so
important even though I put it on my
pinky finger which is little because
that's only true unless there are clear
benefits to having nuclear weapons like
increased legitimacy and access and
power unless the world becomes less
stable and citizens of a country feel
that they need to protect themselves
unless long-standing alliances that have
held the world together for a long long
time start to erode unless international
law becomes less powerful unless the
work of generations of experts is not
respected and upheld and continue the
barriers to making nuclear weapons are
falling and the penalties for doing it
are becoming less effective so countries
that want nuclear weapons it's gonna be
easier for them to get them and so the
path forward maybe is to do what we've
been doing which is to create a world
where there are less benefits to having
the clear weapon and so the list of
countries that want nuclear weapons is
short not because they're afraid of
being penalized but because there's just
not a lot of advantage to having them
building that world was a complicated
process that involved a lot of
compromise and a lot of hard work by
good people like lots of them lots of
people working hard together because
like any relationship global
relationships are lots of work and while
we often only see the failings these
decades of non-proliferation and a world
in which nuclear weapons have only been
used two times during war which I
recognize was done by my country that's
a remarkable testament to people working
together that's not to say that we
didn't screw up at all during those 73
years and it's not to say that we didn't
have some terrifying near-misses that we
have gotten this far is one part luck
one part hard work by thoughtful people
dedicated to
peace and stability and one part even
more luck I just want to say thank you
to the people who have worked on that
however you worked on it that's
remarkable and also like dang thanks and
I worry that since it's been a fairly
good 73 years we may be getting a little
complacent we maybe are forgetting how
hard we worked for this outcome how bad
it could have gone and how much we need
to keep working to keep this stuff
together because I'm not saying it
couldn't have gone better
but we have done remarkably well John
I'll see you on Tuesday unless no
kidding I'm kidding thank you -
Katherine Gill and Jeffrey Lewis for
consulting with me on this video you can
see my interview with Jeffrey over on
Hanks channel it was a good time it's
about half an hour long we have lots of
good chats and if you're interested in
learning more about something completely
different that is also in the news we
have did a series on the US Court system
over on youtube.com slash complexly
which is complexly new youtube channel
just for our production company where we
can try out new things and have a bit of
a playground all right bye bye